with six films released in the conjuring
franchise so far and at least three more
planned for the near future
out of all these films stuck up our all
possessions created equally or some
spirits more pernicious than others
while the first conjuring film is often
warmly regarded by our fans Annabelle
the prequel er followed in 2014 is not
Annabelle made a respectable 257 million
dollars worldwide for reactions to the
film were far from coin this spin-off
focuses on a couple welcoming their
first child while also being terrorized
by possessed doll that seems intent on
taking the mother soul what sets
Annabelle apart from other entries in
the conjuring universe is just how stale
and uneventful the overall film feels
throughout most of the film The Haunted
doll holding moves or really even
bothers a couple who owns her outside of
some shots of Annabelle looking
intimidating or being positioned
ominously in a room there isn't really
much to keep audiences on the edge of
their seats
the curse of lier owner follows a mother
trying to protect her children from the
titular undead spirit the film wastes
what could have been an interesting look
at an underrepresented piece of Hispanic
folklore by instead making it into a
formulaic ghost movie the current sister
really have any interesting
personalities particularly the children
who function more as props to drive the
plot than as actual human beings
motherhood in conventional ideas about
protecting children are highlighted
extensively but there's ultimately no
commentary about those themes in the
ends the film says nothing meaningful
and only manages to deliver a few cheap
jump scares before the spirits is
defeated and the film ends with its
gothic set design and period costumes
the nun might be the most visually
interesting entry in the franchise
however a nicely constructed set and
some interesting costumes not enough to
make a film function and it's safe to
say viewers weren't impressed overall
the film follows an officia - is
determined to find the root of the evil
now emanating from the monastery and
banished a spirit that has taken the
form of an undead nun the known is
packed with a handful of boring OneNote
characters plenty of lazy dialogue and a
deluge of forgettable jump scares
ultimately the nun manages to feel
completely flat and devoid of creative
substance despite having some stylistic
flair Annabelle comes home serves as
another prequel to the first conjuring
film after ed and Lorraine Warren come
into possession of the curse Annabelle
doll the couple safely confined the
possessed plaything away from the world
of course one slip-up is all it takes
for Annabelle to cause havoc when a girl
wanders into the Warren's locked
artifact room and that's identity
releases Annabelle chaos reigns now free
to terrorize as she pleases
Annabelle releases a slew of angry
spirits from the couple's collection of
cursed objects turning the once peaceful
Warren home into a demonic house of
horrors while Annabelle comes home isn't
the worst film in the conjuring universe
it is definitely one of the most boring
with a few exceptions the demons are
noteworthy enough to make them stand out
from the more interesting casts of and
holy spirits who've seen in previous
films the conjuring 2 is one of the best
received entries in the conjuring series
but it still feels a little like the
creative team tried and failed to
recapture lightning in a bottle with
this sequel like the first movie the
conjuring 2 follows ed and Lorraine
Warren has they worked to save a family
from the demon that's tormenting them
the film feels like it was made with the
intention of setting up an expanded
universe instead of telling a complete
self-contained story aside from the
crowded roster of spirits the primary
demon gives us name to the rain in the
beginning of the movie which is the key
to defeating it in the end
making the resolution feel rushed and
then earned I dunno I asked you despite
these gripes ikonn during - is still a
worthy successor to the first film
making use of interesting camerawork a
slow build-up and the creepy imagery
that fans of the franchise have come to
expect featuring a cast of likable
characters lots of creepy build-up and
tense pacing Anabelle creation
reaffirmed at the conjuring series can
still deliver the paranormal frights the
horror fans crave as a prequel to the
first Annabelle film and about creation
shows the origin of the demonic
Annabelle doll the film features
competent acting from the cast of child
actors and decent writing to support
them as well those some of the scares
end up falling flat there are some
genuinely visceral moments that help
drive home the sadistic nature of the
demon there is a unique balance in
Annabelle creation between highlighting
the emotional punishment and job by the
possessed and the physical punishment
doled out by the sadistic spirits
letting the two complement each other
and build an anxiety inducing ways the
first entry in the franchise is also the
best because there was no pre-existing
familiar film universe for audiences the
conjuring had to be particularly paced
instead of being thrown into the
paranormal with little explanation the
characters are forced to do research
sets up and monitor equipment and work
with local police just to get enough
proof to have an exorcism approved as a
result of all the added legwork not only
does a conjuring feel more believable
and accessible for audiences but the
frightening payoffs feel earned the
chief mark of this film's quality is a
building of atmosphere this is
demonstrated particularly well through
how reserved and understated some of the
scares are in the film the musical score
is allowed to be soft and to serve as a
backgrounds are scarce instead of the
blaring bass heavy blaster punctuate
jump cues in later movies
additionally the minimal CGI used
throughout the film is also done with
precision demonstrating that less really
is more check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]